mais la meinau un tel monsieur bonsoir
en devenant secrétaire d'état à la
condition féminine
françois giroux directrice de
l'hebdomadaire l'express et la quatrième
femme à faire son entrée au gouvernement
il était 13 heures exactement lorsque la
nouvelle a été rendue officielle
françoise giroud avait été reçue ce
matin pendant un quart d'heure à
l'elysée par le président giscard
d'estaing avant de se rendre à l'hôtel
matignon pour un entretien plus
approfondi avec le premier ministre
monsieur jacques chirac
à 58 ans françoise giroud estime je cite
qu'elle n'a pas été appelé à ce poste
pour faire de la décoration mais elle
veut effectivement tenter d'améliorer le
sort des femmes dans notre pays
écoutez plutôt ses toutes premières
impressions à l'hôtel matignon sur le
perron françoise giroud apparaît un peu
surprise efforts souriante
je crois que c'est un poste important
dans l'esprit du président de la
république et du premier ministre
je crois qu'ils attachent beaucoup de
frias que la condition féminine soit
considérée amélioré à ce que l'égalité
des droits
il s'annonce pas recherché en tout cas
c'est matin je n'ai pas eu à poser des
conditions parce que tout ce qu'on va
dire de la pensée que pourrait exercer
cette fonction convenablement
vous avez continué à écrire avec ce
brave dame you je crois que je pourrais
écrire certainement pas régulièrement je
vais pas je crois que ce ne serait pas
convenable d'être à la fois chroniqueur
de l'express et d'avoir une pension
gouvernementale mais je pense que
j'aurai la liberté d'écrire de temps en
temps au tout cas en ce qui concerne les
matières dont je vais voter je crois que
nous vivons dans une société où l'on
s'efforce d'obliger la physiologie
féminine à s'adapter à un monde masculin
que ce n'est pas très heureux ni pour
l'épargné pour les hommes mais qui n'est
absolument pas de raison que les fans
des familles le droit d'avoir dans la
société
non seulement la place qui leur revient
par là pour la capacité mais parle le
rôle qu'elle joue dans l'est du pays et
déjà françoise giroud secrétaire d'état
à la condition féminine s'apprête sans
tarder à exercer ses nouvelles fonctions
est ce qu'il ya une date de fixée pour
cette prise de responsabilités et je
crois qu'elle est immédiate
que ce soit en principe assister au
conseil des ministres de demain matin a
bien sûr j'aimerais vous sexy des idées
sur le fait qu' il faut faire en
descente et violine s'améliorer
sensiblement
travaillons dans le sens de la rochelle
et l'égalité des droits des femmes et
des hommes dans ce pays
pour lui mieux des femmes et des hommes
je ne voudrais pas surtout que l'on
pense parce que je ne le pense pas
qu'ils aient travaillé pour les femmes
consiste à travailler contre les hommes
c'est vrai